according to heat Street Ontario has now
passed a law that would allow the
government to invade your home and strip
you of your child if your little Billy
comes home from school one day and
announces he's a little Sally and if you
have the temerity to tell him that he is
not in fact Sally by a shockingly broad
margin of sixty three to twenty three
the supporting Children Youth and
Families Act of 2017 passed through the
Ontario legislature
it tells Child Services and judges to
consider factors including race ancestry
place of origin colour ethnic origin
citizenship family diversity disability
creed sex sexual orientation gender
identity and gender expression in
removing a child from the home Michael
kouto who is the minister of Child and
Family Services was explicit in his
tyranny he said quote I would consider
that a form of abuse when a child
identify one way and a caregiver is
saying no you need to do this
differently if it's abuse and if it's
within the definition a child can be
removed from that environment and placed
into protection where the abuse stops if
all of this sounds bizarre that's
because it is it is also fascism to
remove a child from the home because the
government disagrees with basic biology
is beyond the pale of the reasonable
unfortunately it's not going to be long
before leftist in the United States push
the same thing the first step on that
road is the widely acclaimed spate of
legislation banning so-called conversion
therapy for children with homosexual
tendencies this is not an argument in
favor of the efficacy of conversion
therapy which is iffy in even the best
circumstances but if a child is
disturbed by homosexual feelings and you
bring that child to a therapist to talk
it through that would now be considered
illegal in states including California
and New Jersey as Scot Shackleford of
Reason that magazine explains quote bans
on conversion therapy are fundamentally
censorship of an idea and there's a
slippery slope and consequences that
people with narrow interests in halting
abusive treatments of gay and
transgender teens simply do not grasp
this isn't a ban on particular dangerous
technique like electroshock treatment
for example it's a ban on anything even
just speech coming from a licensed
therapist that suggests homosexuality
can be cured it is dangerous to allow
the government to control the
classification of speech and to recast
speech as something else just because
commerce is involved the next step will
undoubtedly be removing children from
parents who pursue such therapy in spite
of the ban purportedly for the good of
the child the left next step could be to
remove accreditation from schools that
do not traffic in LGBT advocacy after
all California
attempted to remove nonprofit status
from the Boy Scouts schools in
California have now mandated that kids
learn about LGBT history in public
schools what happens when people home
schools and the state decides that
homeschooling is inappropriate for
children if they aren't taught the
state's educational approach it's not
difficult to imagine Child Protective
Services removing children whose parents
won't teach them positively about the
full spectrum of sexual orientation in
the interests of the child of course or
leftist could skip directly to the
Ontario scenario they could claim that
transgender children are being shackled
by their bigoted parents and must be
protected by the state this is scary
stuff it's particularly scary not only
for religious parents but for anyone who
understands that there is no evidence
that transgender feelings among children
are unchanging the vast majority of
children with such feelings grow out of
them or that boys cannot actually become
girls in Ontario the state has now
placed itself in direct opposition to
science and freedom in the United States
the movement to do the same must be
stopped now before families are torn
apart on behalf of a propagandistic
sexual agenda I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
lots against you today President Trump
is now taking on the Mayor of London we
are also going to be talking about this
leak of this leaker who was arrested
whose name was reality winner yes that
was actually the name of the leaker
reality winner who was in reality a
loser and also if your last name is
winner I'm just going to recommend a few
ideas for you for children cross-court
forehand backhand big lottery all of
these would be preferable to reality but
before we get to any of that I want to
talk about one of our sponsors bull and
branch so I've said before on the show I
am NOT a solid sleeper I sleep very
poorly at night typically but I have not
been sleeping poorly since I've been
using bull and branch cheats that's
because they are 100% organic cotton
they really breed they're super
comfortable they are so comfortable that
I literally threw out all of my other
set sheets and bought a couple more sets
of bull and branch sheets and you can
try them right now for 30 nights and if
you don't like them you can send them
back for a refund bull and branch comm
promo code bed you get $50 off your
first set of sheets Plus free shipping
three ex-presidents plus President
Clinton if he's one of those his lovers
sleep on pole and branches they are the
best in the business
there's a reason that they are so great
quality sheets can cost up to $1,000
bonus sheets are a small small fraction
of that but again it's something you're
sleeping on every night there's no
excuse not to treat yourself with bull
and branch sheets bo LL and branch comm
promo code been $50 off your first set
of sheets Plus free shipping again
that's Bo LL and branch comm promo code
Ben and use that promo club Ennis that
they know that that we sent you as well
as getting that $50 off that first set
of sheets plus free shipping it'll
totally change your sleep pattern it'll
it'll you're never going to be able to
sleep on other sheets it's that good
okay so big news today is that a leaker
has now been arrested President Trump
has been very worried about people
inside the intelligence community
leaking against him but this leaker was
arrested after leaking material to a
leftie publication called the intercept
the intercept is sort of sympathetic to
the Edward Snowden position on
intelligence and this leaker whose name
as I say is reality lay winner 25
she was arrested by the FBI at her home
on Saturday
June 3rd and it was probably about the
people are still not sure but it was
supposedly about this document that she
passed on to the intercept that showed
that a couple of days before the
election the Russians were attempting to
hack into actual voting machines in the
United States which would of course
throw the entire election system into
turmoil
they've always been these conspiracy
theories about how it would happen in
2000 there there are conspiracy theories
in 2000 and in 2016 as well that these
voting machines were actually hacked and
that's why Trump won is because the
Russians were going in and actually
manipulating the final voting outcome
there's still no evidence that they
succeeded in that the document from the
NSA that was leaked by reality winner
did not actually show that the Russians
were successful in their attempts to
hack it to show that they tried to but
she was arrested Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein he said exceptional law
enforcement efforts allowed us to
quickly identify an arrest the defendant
releasing classified material without
authorization threatens our national
security and undermines public faith in
government people who are trusted with
classified information and pledged to
protect it must be held accountable when
they violate that obligation so
apparently according to the criminal
complaint reality winner I'm never going
to get tired of saying that name I just
feel like reality winner should have at
some point dated Carlos danger and they
should all touch the orb together and
they should say Cubs Heaphy maybe we've
now reached peak stupid I think in 2017
but every time I say that there's like
another two weeks ago by and we're even
stupider than that so we're in the
alternative timeline in which Marty
McFly did not prevent Biff from using
the sports Almanac in order to bet on on
games in any case the criminal complaint
alleges the would a winner a contractor
with pluribus international corporation
was employed at a US government agency
facility in Georgia since roughly
February 13th and she held a top-secret
clearance sometime around May 9th she
printed and improperly removed
classified intelligence reporting which
contained classified national defense
information from an intelligence
community agency illegally kept it and
then illegally transmitted the
intelligence reporting to an online news
outlet which would be the intercept and
again I guess the way that they tracked
her down is the intercept printed the
actual copy of the document and the show
that the document had been folded which
looked like it had been an actual
original document that was printed out
at the facility folded up putting
pocket and then walked out so then they
were able to look at who exactly had
access to these documents and who had
printed it out and they came up with her
so well done the intercept protecting
your your leaker just genius job they're
really well done but the amazing thing
the amazing thing is I think we're going
to have to issue a in a ban on the
importation of people into government
service until we know what the hell is
going on because our extreme vetting is
just not working it is just not working
here is the fact reality winner again a
person whose name I will never tire
saying reality winner if you looked at
her Twitter feed this is not a person
who should have ever had top-secret
security clearance top-secret security
clearance usually includes not just a
criminal background check and employment
history but also a background
investigator verifies all the
information does a grueling and lengthy
process of speaking to past employers
neighbor spouses ex-spouses and
acquaintances to determine whether
you're trustworthy enough to be given
clearance according to the balance com
which is an employment site it covers a
10-year period and they give you a
polygraph in many cases but they didn't
check her Twitter feed okay like two
days literally two days before she
started working for the federal
government she went on Twitter and she
responded to a tweet from avid sorry
javad zarif is the dictator or the the
foreign minister rather of the Iranian
terrorist government he said we will
never use our weapons against anyone
except in self-defense
let us see if any of those who complain
can make the same statement talking
about talking about nuclear use and and
reality winners sweeted back there are
many Americans protesting US government
aggression towards Iran if our tangerine
in chief declares war we stand with you
okay she had top-secret clearance and
she was saying with top-secret clearance
that if the United States had to go to
war with Iran she would side with Iran
um what how did she where's the extreme
vetting am i concerned about the ability
of our government to vet people who are
coming in from abroad yes but I am even
more concerned if we can't vet the
people who are getting cops I don't have
top security clearance to you I think I
don't in this room as top security
clearance I got I'd be given top
security clearance under the standards
of the federal government because I'm
very outspoken to my political views but
this gal went on Twitter and she's just
sounding off on whatever she felt like
sounding off on there's one point where
she tweeted at Kanye
Wes again this is after shoes working
for the federal government in February
2017 quote you should make a shirt that
says being white is terrorism mm-hmm
yeah this person got top-secret
clearance oh well done federal
government as always just doing a
stellar job now the left is jumping on
the arrest of reality winner to say a
couple of things one they're saying Oh
Trump is going after leakers how dare
Trump go after leakers it's just so
terrible okay first of all let me just
point out that Trump going after leakers
Obama would have gone after this leak or
two I mean the idea that this was in any
way illegal or acceptable it's just
nonsense anyone would have gone after
reality winner but what the Democrats
are really jumping on is the fact that
the documents that she exposed said that
these voting machines were hacks with
Tim Kaine the vice presidential
candidate along with Hillary Clinton in
2016 he said that he thinks that it's
not out of the realm of possibility that
Hillary actually won the election and
that the russians hacked the voting
machines thanks the vote count
could have been affected by the Russians
oh I definitely think so and let's just
make a let's make a distinction here I
don't think anybody has suggested that
the actual tallies on the machines were
affected although that's certainly
something we should look at but I
haven't heard anybody suggest that
there's evidence that that occurred but
when the when the combined way to the
intelligence committees say that Russia
was engaging in a wide-ranging pattern
of action to affect the election to say
there was we can determine that there
was no effect you'd be foolish to say
that especially when you add to the
leaking of information the fact that
they were sucking data about individuals
outside of state boards of Elections and
again and that is all publicly reported
material that I'm giving you
so look they intended to affect the
outcome we have to get to the bottom of
everything they did so we can protect
future elections
we won't rule it out the idea that they
actually hack the election results I'm
just wondering here again if you're
moving without evidence on this thing to
suggest that it's possible the actual
election was hacked which is what
Democrats have been saying for a year
now is the the actual election attackers
since the election and then saying the
actual electrical attack you should
actually have to show some evidence of
that because otherwise you are just
participating in exactly
Democrats were whining about leading up
to the 2016 elections saying Republicans
wouldn't accept the outcome we are now
months and months and months beyond the
election they still won't accept the
outcome and there again buying into the
notion without evidence that the actual
election results were hacked they keep
saying the election was hack it was not
but I think the broader point here is
not about the insanity of the Democrats
which is consistent it is that it is
very difficult to vet people it's very
difficult to vet people which means we
have to be extraordinarily strict
extraordinarily stringent about who we
let into the country and give the
priorities and privileges of citizenship
so here's an example we we in in West we
are very cordial about our rights
obviously and we should be but that very
often veers into the stupidity of either
granting top security clearance to
people who shouldn't have it as in the
case of reality winner or pretending
that violent jihadis are not violent
jihad ease because they live in the West
so for example there's this terrorist
whose name is but that's really his name
his name is Kurama Shahzad but and this
is one of the London terrorists and he
was featured in a documentary on the BBC
about jihadis it was called the jihadi
next door and he was actually on that
documentary and yet they still were not
keeping tabs on him enough to stop him
from helping commit this London Bridge
terror attack here's video of Corrado's
on but in the jihadi in the train in
jihadi next door
you can see this guy this happen Aikido
please come on somebody doesn't come to
kill Allah and it would go smoke oh oh
so I think in the book he just gotta
have fun at the duration prepare for
awesome so this is a type of jihad for
you that you came out to do Dawa in
joining good and forbidding evil and
don't me did said son I wanna class to
be looked a lot are some details on you
will not speak to know
I'm nervous time you say horked it was
insane for the parents a sir are you
insane
alright so for watching no good times
what a powerful suck okay and you can
see this actual terrorist being
confronted by a cop and then the cop is
surrounded by a bunch of young Muslim
guys here is here's the question why is
it that the West seems so bad at betting
and the answer is because we in the West
have a basic assumption which is that
all the people who live in the West are
going to appreciate the privileges and
values of the West that is absolutely
untrue it's absolutely untrue and
because we assume that we make the
mistake of granting privileges and
immunities to people who ought not have
them the fact that this guy appeared on
a documentary called the jihadi next
door means you should have been under
24-hour surveillance this is insanity
it's insanity you all know about all the
red flags great peace by Aaron Bandler
over at daily wired today about all the
red flags on this particular terrorist
okay not only was he on this jihadi
nextdoor documentary but also in 2015
but police were alerted about him when
he attempted to spread Islamic
propaganda children in a park she
confronted issues he was confronted by a
mother after her two children came home
and said mummy I want to become a Muslim
she passed along the information he was
trying to radicalize the children said
the mother who'd go down to the park and
talk to them about Islam and he tried to
recruit them to Islam and the police of
course let that go a friend of butts
also reported him to the police due to
comments he made to justify a terror
attack apparently one of his friends
phoned the anti-terror hotline and they
told him about the conversation and why
he was radicalized and nothing happened
he is also he was part of a radical
Islamic organization known as all
muhajirun which is a which is lobbied
for Sharia law and has been linked to
50% of all terror attacks in Britain
over the past 20 years he wanted to wage
jihad in Syria according to a relative
of Bucks wife but never acknowledged
women in conversation he was kicked out
of a mosque for arguing with an imam
during a sermon they've been conducting
surveillance of a terrorist cell in the
London town of barking where but lived
since March and they missed him the day
of the attack but asked his neighbor
where he could find a van and again it's
he was known to the met police and the
Metropolitan Police as well as mi5 but
they didn't touch him because obviously
that would be politically incorrect when
President Trump says that he's very
upset about the political correctness
that dominates when it comes to policing
of Islamic jihadism
he is absolutely right we should also be
just as we should be just as as
attentive to the fact that there are
people who are something to get top
security clearance about political
motivations again if you express one
thing just to be you know politically
left it's not a big deal but if you are
somebody who is expressing sympathy for
the Iranian regime over the United
States I think that it's probably a
mistake to give you top security
clearance vetting vetting vetting I know
the left has basic principle they never
want to engage in risk calculation they
think all risk calculation is profiling
okay all criminal behavior can be
profiled through risk calculation but
attempting to profile through risk
calculation is considered racist sexist
xenophobic politically incorrect by the
left and that's why you end up with bad
people slipping through the cracks well
in just a second I'm be joined by
Senator Mike Lee of Utah he's a brand
new book out but before I get to that I
want to say thank you to our sponsor is
over at my Patriot supply so are you
concerned about the direction of
security are you concerned about
terrorism are you concerned about the
possibility of the big terror attack
that would leave you cut off from
supplies or a big natural disaster
that's why you need to go to prepare
with been calm or call eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen for
Paris been calm eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen for your
four-week emergency food supply for just
$99 plus free shipping you get that four
week emergency food supply keep your
family safe had apparently tastes
exactly like home cooking according to
people in the office prepare with been
calm it's prepare with been calm you
know you buy it once you never have to
worry about it again eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen prepare
with been calm be the person who's
prepared in case of emergency your
family is going to thank you for it
again $99 for a four week emergency food
supply okay so yesterday we had the
opportunity to speak with Senator Mike
Lee and here is a bit of our
conversation through it with with the
great senator from Utah maybe the last
honest man neither in the United States
Senate well joining us here now on the
bench Shapiro show is my favorite
senator the the last honest senator in
America Senator Mike Lee of Utah he has
the benefit of also being from a state
that actually elects conservatives
everyone
a while so Senator Mike Lee has a brand
new book out called written out of
history The Forgotten founders who
fought big government its soaring up the
charts at Amazon it was all the way up
to number number seven on the Amazon two
bestsellers we want to bring it all the
way up to number one so if you can go
over to Amazon right now and by written
out of government Forgotten founders
have forgot who fought big government
senator Lee thanks so much for joining
me she'll appreciate it thank you but so
now when we jump right into the book
because it's it's fascinating that
everybody reads the Federalist Papers
nobody reads the anti-federalist papers
and if they'd read the anti-federalist
papers they would understand that a lot
of the debates that were had back then
are being here today except with a
government that is much bigger your book
is about so not necessarily people who
are writing in the anti-federalist
papers but people who were bringing a
different point of view to bear even at
the time of the founding about the
overreach of federal government so let's
run through through some of these people
because I think it really is fascinating
content so start with Aaron Burr who's
been portrayed as the great villain of
American history now of course Hamilton
is a big here at everybody because
there's musical that very few people
have seen but everyone has heard of and
and Aaron Burr is is portrayed largely
by a guy who ended up as a guy who ended
up as a traitor trying to destroy the
country
what exactly is the true story of Aaron
burn how'd he impact the building of the
country Aaron Burr was himself of was a
victim of overreaching president Thomas
Jefferson who at this political rate
both he became obsessed with his own
power he wanted by threat when Aaron
Burr was vice president under Thomas
Jefferson as vice president's also
president of the Senate there were a
number of people who were themselves the
victims of Jefferson's
political road rage who found themselves
receiving end of impeachment proceedings
Aaron burbs
as president of the Senate a sort of
them due process in fairness this bother
Thomas Jefferson a lot it also bothered
if Aaron Burr was still a political
threat to him so later during Gibson's
second term when there was no longer
exposure
Jefferson went after and accused him of
treason prosecuted him for treason a
capital offense the what course and
language in the Constitution burr would
have lost
life it's not as Jefferson ever now look
Jeff and it's amazing he was a great
mind the author of the Declaration of
Independence but he wasn't perfect and
this story in the story of aaron
berger's an offensive is a last reminder
to us that even a wise bright man Thomas
Jefferson could be corrupted by power
should always beware it is fascinating
me to talk about that because obviously
you know now there's a lot of talk about
whether it's necessary to have character
in government there's a lot of talk
after this last election cycle where a
lot of people were concerned about the
character of both major candidates for
for presidents of the United States and
a lot of people it seems to basically
come to the conclusion after the Clinton
years that character doesn't matter in
the president at all and we should just
pick somebody the system will handle
itself there's not really a great threat
what do what do you make of that
argument in light of in light of
American history well I think what we
have to remember is that when even a
good person is someone who might use
power we have to carefully cabin that
down I remember when I was seeing a
movie where there was this ironical King
I remember the name of the moment but
the tyrant king got really mad one day
and said that's it I'm canceling
Christmas I thought what kind of society
even gives power to the King to cancel
Christmas
they shouldn't ever do that in the first
place you don't want to give our gulity
to take away something is fundamental to
people is their religious holidays so
regardless of where you start with the
first even a person who is an absolute
Saint should not be trusted with
unlimited power the entire family
generation routing the people I focus on
in my book written out of history
we're suspicious of government power
everyone expect the George Washington to
be our first private they all respected
George Washington but they still
deliberately created a relatively weak
presidency meaning someone would have
too much power the first place to abuse
well the book is written out of history
the forgotten founders who fought big
government another name that people will
know but may not know about him is
Elbridge Gerry
everybody knows his name because the
gerrymandering of course and there are
so many lawsuits now about whether
districts have been properly drawn
because they are
gerrymandered but what exactly was
Elbridge Gerry x' role in the in
founding of the country well he was
delegate to the Constitutional
Convention he was one of those who had
some real curious concerns with the
Constitution even at the end of the
drafting process he was in many respects
the the forbear maybe a progenitor of
the Bill of Rights he was the author of
the language that became the tenth
amendment only his version of the 10th
amendment would have been better it
contained one word that's lacking in the
10th amendment as it was ultimately
drafted and ratified and that is
expressed with the way Gerry wrote it
originally it would have been all powers
not expressly granted to Congress or
prohibited to the states are reserved to
the States or to the people and James
Madison took that out took out the word
express thinking it was unnecessary many
decades later about 150 years later I I
think Elbridge theory was proven right
under we would have been better off as
the word expressly been included so I
want to talk a little bit about applying
the lessons of written out of history to
modern government so obviously the
government has grown far more than any
of the founders ever would have
perceived the battles between the
Federalists and anti-federalists and the
people who are critical of government
power at the time centralization of
power and the people who are in favor of
that centralization of power john adams
who was a big proponent of a stronger
executive and a stronger federal
government even he would look at the
situation now and probably vomit never
stop vomiting because none of these guys
were in favor of the the overarching
federal government that we have now how
do we pare that back because it seems
like we have an incentive system where
Congress has an incentive to pass
incredibly vague laws and blame all of
the implementation on the executive the
executive has the incentive to continue
accruing as much power to itself as
humanly possible and the Supreme Court
and the court system has as much
incentive as possible to increase their
own power by green-lighting federal
powers so where exactly can we stop this
cycle is it an article v convention is
it we're just gonna have to wait for
people to wise up and learn American
history because that may take a while
what what exactly can we do not only
citizens what can you do in Congress to
actually help effectuate this okay great
question that's it this is actually
something that's the part of why I wrote
this book regardless of the mechanics
whether it occurs for an article five
convention which is an option whether it
occurs a series of legislative reforms
or constitutional reforms brought about
within Kurvers uh regardless of our path
not going to happen until it has to
happen so the people insist on it but
that in turn isn't going to occur and
fill systemic people V acquaint
themselves with our true feelings port
our modern-day accounts of America's
founding and uh propounding and sanitize
it been sanitized my educational and
political and media establishment that
wants a single narrative what could be a
sort of post New Deal era narrative to
dominate the discussion and so as a
result what we've all been taught in
public school in college even then most
private school is that those who
advocated for a bigger stronger national
government are the ones to be revered
the anti-federalists Luther mark who I
discuss in the book have been sort of
cast aside the problem is if we don't
have both sides of the story being told
once the American people become
reacquainted with the other side of the
story the one that's been written out of
history and they can begin to exercise
the political will and and move forward
these local again whether it's through
an article five convention or otherwise
there will have to be there from the
part of the people but the people are
going to have the will until they report
themselves with these stories and so
these become part of our national
floating disc works we're talking with
Senator Mike Lee author of written out
of history The Forgotten founders who
fought big government I'd be remiss
senator lief I didn't ask you a little
bit about what's going on in the Senate
right now just in terms of politics
we're looking at we're now a hundred and
fifty days into the Trump administration
and aside from the Congressional review
act no major legislation has really
passed through Congress do you foresee
there being a major tax reform bill
given the the hub of that's happening
over over healthcare right now it seems
like in order to get a good tax reform
bill through they need to get some sort
of health care reform through in order
to build up the savings that they can
use to pass on those
to reconciliation for purposes of tax
reform do you think that we're going to
get one of those neither of those and it
brought a question as a follow-up would
it be better if we just stop with all
these omnibus packages in general and
started passing three page bills that
everybody could vote up or down yes so
let me let me deal with your last
question first absolutely which is one
of my biggest frustration for the place
is that for years and years or at least
a six and a half year period of stupid
Congress has not been appropriating so
there's passing bills that spend money
through the regular order process in
other words we wait until the deadline
we run right up to the limit placed on a
spending bill usually September
thirtieth and then we're full you either
pass this bill there are a continuing
resolution for an omnibus spending
package or the government's going to
check them take it relief and by the way
in this package the CR or missus or
whatever it is it's going to fund
Planned Parenthood it's going to fund
all these bad things you jump back to
your phone Obamacare but you have to do
this or you're going to get blamed for
something that's how it's been working I
wish we would think this in a
step-by-step fashion perhaps much
smaller more granular spending bills so
that we can bring the attention to each
individual area of government spending
with respect to your other question
about tax reform in Obamacare review
look I believe both of those are going
to have I'm probably in the minority in
saying that it could be super from those
who are speaking out and talking the
reason I think that it has to well we
the Republican Party is going to be in
serious serious jeopardy if it doesn't
pass both of those and those people seem
to think that the Obamacare we feel
needs to come first for next reasons I'm
agnostic on that point I actually do it
together if you want to sit but
regardless we have to pass both of them
and if you don't worry for a role world
of trouble that's usually where
something happened in Washington it's
where members of Congress were made
aware of the fact there's going to be
hell to pay if they don't do it I think
we're in that circumstance or by macare
review and with tax reform and I
therefore that something lap Senator
Mike Lee thanks so much for joining the
show the book again is written out of
history The Forgotten founders who
fought big government
if you definitely check it out you can
hear obviously senator Lee is super
fluent not only in American history but
also in governance and this is a must
read for people who are concerned about
the future of government just as they
should be about the passive American
government you can't understand where we
are without knowing where we've been and
what the arguments were on the other
side many of which were actually correct
as time went on it was proved that they
were correct senator Lee thanks so much
for joining the show keep doing what
you're doing obviously we're big
admirers here at the show so thank you
so much thank you very much okay so I
want to discuss president Trump's battle
with the London Mayor City Khan in just
a second but for that you're going to
have to go over to Daley wired.com
become a subscriber for just $8 a month
you can be a subscriber at Daley
wire.com see the rest of the show live
you can also see the the rest of Clavin
show live you can be card the mailbag
which we're gonna be doing on Fridays
now because thanks to the addition of a
fifth show a week yes that's right we
are now broadcasting every single
weekday yeah so $8 a month we'll get you
that annual subscription we'll get you a
free signed copy of the new book that I
have that with my father say it's so
Papa Dada me and the 2005 White Sox
championship season it is a great
Father's Day gift it's perfect for your
dad I know cuz I wrote it with mine so
it's a lot of fun endorse by Mark Levin
and Dana Perino and Jerry crafts Nick
over at espn.com really good baseball
book not political so much as it is just
about relationships and father and son
stuff you can get a free signed copy of
that when you go over to Daley wire comm
and become an annual subscriber even if
you're a regular subscriber if you
upgrade to an annual subscription then
you can get a free signed copy as well
okay we are the largest conservative
podcast in the country
[Music]
you